tu restes comme ça si tu pars comme ça
si tu vois que pendant le match on est
dans un quart d'heure ou vraiment leur
route dessus qu'on récupère un ballon
que j'ouvre on joue vite sauf si
vraiment on est dans une zone à risque
dans le but ou dans les 22 là tranquille
on sort du terrain on va en touche
tu vas commencer par fermer les yeux
prendre trois bonnes respirations
inspire
expire et fait monter ce niveau de joie
ce niveau d'enthousiasme à l'intérieur
de toi
ressens le là maintenant ressort cette
énergie dans tes pieds dans tes mollets
dans tes cuisses dans ton ventre ressens
cet enthousiasme porte ton attention sur
les bruits les sons comment l'énergie
tourne dans ton corps
reste connecté à ça et dans cet espace
visualise toi en match là maintenant
inspiration expiration
et à ton rythme tu peux réouvrir les
yeux et garder cette énergie jusqu'au
bout du match
en numéro 1 du coup Lolotte
[Applaudissements]
voilà moi j'ai confiance en vous ayez
confiance en vous et tout se passera
bien merci
va pas falloir qu'on s'éloignant il va
falloir qu'on colle ensemble et qu'on
colle à ce de score elle met en
essai on en met un il va falloir qu'on
soit de morte de faim on soit on
s'en fout on répond on répond direct
mais il va falloir qu'on aille au combat
les meufs il va falloir qu'on y a tout
ensemble et quand on rentre sur le
terrain si on est remplaçant c'est qu'on
est mort de faim
ah
génial je pense que là ça va être un
match difficile parce que même si il
fait beau il y a beaucoup de vent donc
les pâtes j'ai pas qu'elles arrivent pas
et elles sont voilà elles sont elles
sont elles sont quand même pas mal Paris
15 donc voilà il y a du stress mais je
sens l'équipe super motivée là vraiment
il y a une bonne ambiance tu le sens
comment tondu mais ça va ça va le faire
ça va être chaud
1 2 3 4 5 6 7
mettez-moi les trois quarts sur les
quatre plots ici les avances sur les
trois plots vite
les boucliers esprits
OK
on pensait qu'il mettrait au moins une
équipe pour nous respecter il nous
respecte pas ils font démarrer leur
équipe on va leur rouler dessus il vous
prend une pour des petits ils vont ils
veulent vous prendre de haut on va leur
rouler dessus faut qu'on leur montre
qu'on est chez nous faut qu'on leur
montre tout de suite qu'on a les crocs
la fille elle est trop bas vous la ratez
c'est pas grave on va tout le monde va
rater des plaquages aujourd'hui ce qui
est important c'est celui d'après si
chacune vous gagnez vous rencontrent ça
va le faire je veux que mes remplaçantes
aujourd'hui elles sont meilleures que
les titulaire c'est bon pour tout le
monde allez serrer serrer serrer serrer
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait totalement sortie
de son
lâche pas Marina
oui 4 OH les amis
qu'est-ce qu'elle nous fait plonge dans
le rock là qu'est-ce qui est bon sans
déconner on se prend tous les matchs on
va jouer à 14h ça me casse
mais non mais c'est pas elle en plus
j'ai mis une veste
faut que je le ramène l'eau après
tu lances en tout je suis Alexandre
devant sur les cinq OK
traverse
un éléphants
ah
mais les cocu elle mais comme il faut
j'ai rien demandé de sortir vite sur les
mêlés elle sort pas on prend le vent
avec nous on trouve on trouve pas les
touches
30 secondes
resserrez-vous et on prend que des
bidons ils nous ont rien montré là ils
ont un essai bon à la chatte à Dédé là
vraiment là là on prend des essais sur
coup d'envoi tout pourri et il y a rien
quoi vraiment il y a rien là
vous écartez
ça c'est le premier bloc ça c'est le
deuxième bloc allez les filles allez
resserrez vous allez
on est chez nous il y a rien il y a rien
soyez plus méchants encore plus
méchantes il faut qu'on monte en défense
allez salut
allez allez on y va là il propose rien
il propose rien regarde
danser à nouveau danser à nouveau et
vous me regardez en haut
saute mais on le sait qu'elle saute
premier bloc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais les placages c'est un truc de ouf
[Applaudissements]
faut jouer vite mon beau faut jouer vite
là faut toujours évident pour venir dans
le match faut jouer vite faut jouer vite
oui il faut jouer vite
[Applaudissements]
vous appliquez trop le plan de jeu et
vous sortez pas du plan de jeu on vous a
dit les gros vous défendez dans une zone
proche les trois quarts de loin du coup
quand il y a des zones loin où il y a
personne il y a des vis-à-vis vous
mettez pas en face ayez de l'autonomie
en défense je vous ai gueulé pendant 80
minutes premier bloc et elles ont fait
que des premiers blocs on est tombé sur
l'équipe de Paris 15 qui était qui était
expérimenté et puis dès qu'on est passé
à 14 ça a été le tournant du match on a
pris des essais et puis après
mentalement c'était un petit peu un
petit peu plus dur je trouve qu'il y a
eu quand même un beau collectif on sait
pas on sait pas défiler au placage en
défense alors qu'elles étaient quand
même solides et on est très content de
notre état d'esprit et notre notre
solidarité sur le terrain
[Musique]